I will not play the same person back to
back this is not back to back though but
i do have white back to back against
benko gene let's try see for my opponent
is most likely typing that they are
muting the stream that's their m.o just
muted you this time lost the stream last
time okay let's go here do this oh oh
okay so what's the scoop all right let's
get a pawn in the center development
time catalan ish ish catalan mmm how
could i be a pest let's develop
development what do I want to do
these are good questions when you don't
know what to say construct like what
constructive thing to say just ask
questions and don't give answers it's a
wonderful trick wonderful trick those of
you that might be wanting to broadcast
just ask questions how about castles and
then pick up the bishop pair should I
run for that right now my opponent be
afraid of night here now year Bishop
here h3 Bishop there g4 I'm weakening my
Kings side here quite a bit hmm how can
I get a good pond break in e4 if I can't
do something about this guy and if I
don't do this right now maybe there's H
6 and I could forget about trying to get
the night for Bishop exchange I can do
clean here and if Queen B 6 c5 Queen
takes pawn takes Bishop back up b4 b5 ah
I'll try that I like that better this
Bishop might be slightly misplaced
right Queen B 6 c five forces the forces
the well it really changes the
complexion of the game here we go by
fours the Queen's must come off the
board by force the a file will be open
in by force you haven't heard me say it
enough I will be able to exchange off
this double to be pond because this guy
is unprotected on a eight I might also
want to look into just this I might also
not want to look into that oh no no no
no no I think I really like that move
hmm it's juicy I think I might want to
do it what's the plan from here where's
his dream square where is it can you
guess where does he want to live any
idea those of you that said on a five
you scored two points he would love to
be there how does he get there boom boom
boom is it worth the time invested to do
that though is the other question and I
don't have answers to that but if I had
more time these are lines that I would
certainly be considering another one is
Bishop f4 to d6 just to prevent this 'if
I've break I believe that's one of the
only breaks to maybe get in my opponent
is typing could be wrong but I think the
beep on is going to kill me in this
eventual end game haha now you might
want to track that guy right down do I
do this first though
now my nights gonna take a hike you
might say well what if Bishop see too
well what do you do you play be four you
play rook a two and then you jump in to
be three this is purposeful by the way I
bet you do this right now this break is
going to happen I'm gonna do something
silly looking but i think it's effective
no maybe not pawn push no no no no let's
go for I'm gonna run right after him you
know what I might not do this pawn move
if a five I might do this no I might not
dozen Knight g4 I'm uh clearly confused
right now pawn push pawn push chop-chop
rip check my king is running to f1 oh
man I don't want to do that whoa oh they
felt the pressure they were fearing the
pressure ok so now ok change of a
scenery here scenery has changed how did
it change let's kick this Bishop away so
my opponent was just viewing that that
was just going to be too much to deal
with so they were trying to alleviate my
eventual long-term pressure against b7
if I was able to get the time in and put
them to put a night on 85 now I get the
dark square Bishop I'm going to take
them and my nights still gonna go here
to watch out for c4 I got to move faster
and I just want to get developed now
Bishop d to Bishop b4 let's go [ __ ] up
you're not doing anything Bishop b4 oh I
really don't want to uh I like my night
I don't want oh no no no no no yeah no
no no am i doing I'm not moving fast
this night out of here
and take my bishop what's the material
Kyle here okay if pawn push I get this
guy eventually I'd really have to go
quicker okay Brooke see one this guy is
not doing anything right here let's go I
gotta put pressure on c6 otherwise my
night would be trapped do i do after ye
for or maybe I just do before this is
maybe clear be4 night BTW 395 yep that's
the plan might be 395 let's go night
here we go now i think i got with f3e
for f3 e4 pawn push f 6 pound push i'm
looking at pawn breaks a lot okay um
let's go nite let's go nite come on
night ah ok maybe a king here f45 flush
this King back Bishop here I like King
up right here more central whoa all
right let's go here right now pre move
that less than 50 okay tricky night this
real can't move you can't be too happy
Bishop here maybe at some point
I'm going to do this I want I want to
exchange some stuff I want the five
files to open up and then this becomes
an inconvenience to have one of the
rooks tether to the defense of b7 hmm
let's take like this my Rucka call it
somewhere else right here you can be a
pest watch out for the trickiness
trickiness everywhere around every
corner I think right here this Bishop on
age three works well with my night
possibilities King improvement pawn push
next for a second I was thinking the
bishop had to react i think now i have
this book takes i get the bishop now
let's go here pawn push soon Bishop here
and then pawn push let's go here 27
where's my time ah my opponents gonna
flag me I know it I know what I could
just feel it I don't want to go here
pawn push takes I'm in trouble let's go
here okay I've locked I have a lock i
think and take my bishop connect to pass
ponds oh man oh oh want to go with this
one no this one kings gonna go here
isn't he he is let's go over here
pressure on this guy i'm getting a pond
they missed that my night was there okay
this is definitely collapsing now
where's the mate mate to threat rook
takes half mate into I'm gonna get the
main to this time let's go up on your
fast in your past connected passed pawns
get this rook first have this pond and
then promote one two three okay benko g
always down to the water here good game
let's go back I think you do have an
opportunity to actually not cash in and
grab that minor piece hmm let's see be
very aware of this idea ah
what am I talking about let's get to it
this move right here right here because
of how I can continue with queen bee
three something you might think this
might be one of those positions where
you like you know I give me let's grab
my favorite coin and flip flip it and
see heads east 7 tails d6 know there's a
big difference you go to d6 this Queen B
move Queen to be three Queen B 6 I could
force the situation we could go quickly
from the middle game too I guess it's
still middle game ish because of the it
would only be the Queen's off the board
but we're definitely tending more
towards the endgame if Bishop d6 queen
queen bee three Queen B 6 c5 there's not
really a better way to maybe even defend
this pawn either I think you always kind
of have to be in a position to meet
queen bee three with Queen B 6 and is
the type of position where both sides
benefit from having pawns doubled or
benefit from having an open a file so
what am I getting out maybe there's
something other than Bishop d6 because I
think it turns out well for me after the
Queen's come off and i have this a file
so maybe what you could look into is
night here if queen bee three queen bee
six if c5 you could take my queen
recapture play a six and as soon as i
play be four you get your rook off of
the a file so i can't get in this b5
break this is all very timely very
timely so look into this move right here
connecting your nights instead of the
bishop mo retain your bishops options in
fact um maybe he does want to go here
later but at least retain that
flexibility for your king bishop this
night he only has one option might as
well throw them in there on d 7 I think
if this capture occurs d if black gives
up the center it allows for an IT 5 i'm
going to get this pond back and i'm also
in a position then play efore
tempeh so I'm not so sure about giving
up the center in this position so anyhow
just some quick thoughts there's a lot
more to be said for this position but it
definitely gets into a critical line
right here Queens coming off and i get b
5 in successfully and well i press
forward and i get a night on a 5 long
term that's going to be an issue maybe
your other try at this point when I'm
retreating with my night is to break
right away right now right now with e5
if i go here maybe you could take you
beyond my nights off 'if I've I think I
do III takes I want to be able to be in
a spot to just recap with my pond but
then the e-file opens up and i think i
have to run run away with my king 2 and
not so great square i think you can
maybe get in with this e 5 advanced look
into that in this particular position
maybe and then playing on the e-file so
okay